Club you say you're attracted to
dangerous characters
how does waltz fit into that picture do
I say that well no I wouldn't say I'm
attracted to dangerous characters I'm
I'm attracted to characters that have
conflict because for me it's always more
interesting than a character that hasn't
got conflict and it's more real and so a
character that's grappling with
something he's always much more
interested play because you got more
than one thing to play all the time and
this film certainly falls into that
bracket because he's a father estranged
from his son who's trying to make a go
of it and trying to do the right thing
and it's very difficult in his
circumstances and he's got sudden demons
he's dealing with but you know so it
certainly falls into the bracket of you
know a character in conflict sure but
he's redeemable yeah I mean at the end
of the day is you know his intentions
are true and good and he's trying he's
trying to make a go of it but it's not
always easy and the one thing that's
very sweet about this film it's about a
group of characters living in a
particular area and a lot of them have a
very tough time and struggling but it's
very non-judgmental you know it's not a
film that looks down on these people
it's a film that you kind of have
empathy and understand how hard it is
for a lot of people
sure sure I grew up with a single parent
so I could relate to a lot of the scenes
in the film
Jaden for you how did you prepare for
Anthony how did you did you did you go
into sort of what his life would be like
especially in some of the scenes like
sitting in the truck outside the bar I
know that's early in the film so yeah
well he's he's he's this good kid he's
he doesn't usually get into trouble
until he's with his dad he's very
curious about the world and he's curious
about what what his father is dealing
with and I just had to I had to do the
same thing I had I had to think about
the
different different things that was
going on that that were going on with my
father and what would what would he
would what he would think about during
during a moment like if he was in this
truck all alone just I had to think
about what what Anthony would be
thinking about sure well dude you're 13
now I said okay what would you recommend
to another 13 year old on getting into
the business um well of course I I
couldn't have gotten to the business if
I didn't know any anybody or two and
just having this this interest in in
acting and if and if you don't want to
act you don't you don't necessarily have
to and but it's something that you do if
you truly want to do it so um you know
if if if you're interested by acting and
if you're interested in and being
somebody else then you should definitely
pursue and you also want to direct one
day I would like to direct one day um
yeah that's why I'm I'm so happy that I
was able to work with Bob and everybody
else the two of you direct each other at
any point I wouldn't dream of it
wouldn't dream of it